LWIAYYY
Last Week I Asked You
NOTHING (explosion.mp4)
Welcome everyone to LWIAY (:D)
My favourite show...yay 👏👏👏👏👏 (MEME REVIEW)
Fan voted top show of 2018
It's been my pleasure this year (Good)
Wow..can't wait to see what more reddit memes he's going to go through this time
OH (Pewds, are you okay?)
OH x2
OH x3
Lets get into the memes (YEAHH)
WAH
what memes do we got? what happened this week?
why can't I find a guy like this ugh (hmm I wonder?)
hitler: hey
some random girl on the internet: no
vox mom gay: he's literally the guy in the pic
Thank you Vox
VERY COOL
This is what gets top voted? Really?
Can we go back to family friendly-
Alright that's it...that's it. I'm pulling the plug.
(I'm) Christian now. That's right, I'm Christian.
We're 👏👏 back to Christian Channel (THIS HAS GONE TOO FAR)
I had enough. Christian Channel
G O D   D A M M I T--
I mean: GOSH DARNIT*
Hey, look at that! My own video...almost made it.
My own content!
*(evil laugh)*
Thank you guys so much for all this support on this video...
It was really fun for everyone involved, I think...
loli
Let's not. That was a weird-- (Agree)
2016 was a weird time, I'm not gonna lie
YEAH, I don't want to remember that one
Thank you
Thank you (x2) though (You're Welcome)
Thank you (x3) so much
I have such a great fans
During the BROS (The Golden Age)
SQUAD-FAM (The Dark Age)
9 YEARS OLD (The Renaissance)
👏 MeMeStErS 👏
Get it right, you dumbasses
"Damn that's sexy"
How old is a DVD screensaver
(15 years) FBI OH--ah gOsHdArNiT
Alright... I had enough.
(NOOOOOOOO)
The gre- THE GREAT SUBSCRIBER WAR
DID YOU DO YOUR PART?
It ain't over 'til it's over gOsHdArNiT (christian channel, Felix)
commanders and leaders
The best part: 0 deaths!
Don't challenge me... Things might change very soon.
Be careful what you wish for. (Pewdiepie 2018)
Let's confuse new fans of PewDiePie (BARRELS)
I don't get it... What is this supposed to mean?
What is that golden statue??
and why does he look Italian???
sheesh
That's weird...
That's right... I AM. 👏👏 CHRISTIAN CHANNEL 👏👏
waht
omg...hello? (dvd screensaver says otherwise)
what happened?
I'm scared...
CHRISTIAN CHANNEL (wrong I'm atheist)
👏👏 CHRIST--Oh...
Hohh... ChRiStiAn ChAnNeL
That's right everybody, I have converted.
Feel free to...bless my videos
...with as many ads as you please. (if you can't do that remember to like and subscribe)
Thank you very much. (you're welcome)
Ahahahaha (get it?)
👏
👏👏
👏👏👏
That's a great meme... (igiveit dvd/dvd)
Wow...look at that guys.
He put a TV on the wall (Hahaha me too lol )
I think I deserve a whole week off, okay? (I don't think so)
I think I deserve a whole month (ok that's good enough)
I think I've done my part, to say the least.
...y'know I worked hard, what can I say?
Yeah, alright. Yeah, it's not like I got 60k comments
"hEy, yOu SHOuLD mAKE ThE DVD--"
Are you happy now? Is this what you wanted? (NO)
Do you feel contented?
CUS IF YOU SMASH THUMBS UP ON THIS VIDEO (if you don't, do it anyway)
If the DVD corner...hit the corner?
What the hell am I saying? Jesus Christ.
Have I been making videos for 10 years?
Hit the corner
Smash like
Do whatever you want
*groans out in anguish*
A fake ass PewDiePie chair
WTF is that?
Am I supposed to be happy??
Where's the Italian leather???
Where's the- unique PewDiePie design?????
hUH????????????
DON'T TALK TO ME--
Only one chair can properly do this
Don't make me laugh
hEH--
Is that the actual weather there- gOsH DaRn
F*ck that
heh(x3)
(unintelligible words)
eEY
heh
heh(x3)
Hey, that's not bad
It should've сука lasagna
but
very good to say the least
I- I really appreciate all the covers
It's so fun to see
All these fake ass tweets--
I didn't tweet this
yOU AIN'T FOOLING NO ONE-
YOU CAN'T FOOL THE FOOLER--
YOU CAN'T FOOL THE FOOLED---
You're-
You're--
F*ck you
*laugh of shame*
cHRiSTriAN CHaNneL
Any news media
Basically
Bible review-
👏BIBLE REVIEW👏 (impossible)
Who is this f*cking guy?
WHAT IS MY DOPPELGANGER DOING?
sTOP IT--
Let's pray everyone 👏👏
Part 1/500
This is making me uncomfortable ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Like that's too far
A lot of times people send me dopplegangers
Or like-
"oH tHiS LoOKs LiKe PeWDiEpiE--"
And I'm like:
"Yeah, I guess"
bUT THIS IS JUST GENUINELY SCARING ME--
WHAT THE HELL IS THAT???
Who is that man?
I know it's me- I know that's me
I don't like that
What if I can make him-
Make my videos--
And then I don't have to make videos anymore?!
*le gasp*
Find me that man god-
I mean gOsH dArNiT--
WE NEED THIS MAN
PAPA NEEDS A BREAK